You know,
there's this,
there's this play written by a German
named good though I can never say that
properly.
It's Johan van g o e t h e,
and I can't say it,
but he wrote this play called Faust and
he wrote one part of it when he was
quite young and then files to when he
was quite old and he has a character in
there,
Mephistopheles Mephistopheles the devil,
and he actually has the devil explained
himself twice basically using the same
words,
which,
which I really like.
It was very profound.
And basically girth is memphis awfully
says no,
he's the adversary of the word.
That's a good way of putting it,
um,
because that's how it works out.
Mythologically,
he's the figure behind the snake in the
garden of Eden,
which is something we'll talk about
more,
but he has a,
he has a sophisticated philosophy.
He's not just some random troublemaker.
He's got a,
he's got a deep philosophy.
And his philosophy is quite
straightforward and it's compelling.
It's compelling and people are gripped
by it quite often,
far more often than they think.
And his philosophy is,
well,
look around at the world.
It's like I then Karamozov in the
brothers Karamazov when he's trying to
disabuse his younger brother of being a,
a,
a Christian monk.
Mephistopheles says,
well,
look at the world.
I mean,
all you look around the world,
it's nothing but a blood bath.
It's just suffering everywhere.
Everything eats everything and people
die terribly and they're cruel to one
another.
And the whole mass is nothing but a
constant hall of terrible carnage and,
and ruin.
And,
and,
and rec.
He says it,
should it be better if it was never
existed at all.
And that's a very interesting.
That's a very,
very interesting idea.
And I do believe,
and I've seen this in people many times,
that in the depths of despair,
especially when you've been betrayed,
for example,
and you wander into the wrong
subdivision of the underworld.
That's something that comes to mind if
you know you have a very sick child,
for example,
or maybe your whole family is suffering
as whole families do.
Sometimes an idea is going to come to
you.
It's like,
good God who put this message together
and is it really worth it?
Is it really worth this suffering?
Suicidal people,
you know?
They say no.
They say no enough of this.
You know,
and you have to be pushed along way.
Generally speaking before you'll
actually commit suicide.
You have to be in very,
very desperate straits,
but your answer under those conditions
is that being is such that it would be
better if it had never been,
and that's a very.
I think,
I think it's a very.
It's a terrible philosophy,
I believe because I think what happens
if you act it out is that you make the
very things that lead you to despair far
worse and I can't see that.
If it's reasonable to draw a logical
conclusion that suffering should you
justify as your desire to make being in
that the answer to that can be to
produce more suffering.
It just doesn't make sense.
And my observation has been that people
who act out the Memphis defilippo and
philosophy inevitably make suffering far
worse and so and then that raises the
other specter of well do.
They weren't being just to cease or are
they just out for bloody revenge at
every,
at any cost.
And Mike Inclusion has always been that
is that the mask is well being shouldn't
exist because it's too terrible,
but the true motivation is I'm going to
make everyone suffer as much as I
possibly can before I say goodbye to
this place and if you read the writings
of people like the kids who shot up the
columbine high school,
they'll tell you exactly that.
That's precisely and exactly what they
concluded and then act it out.
So anyways.
But in this God says that it was good.
I've thought about that a lot is like
because the question is something like,
well,
is it something better than nothing?
Because that's a really good question.
You know,
and I thought about two things in
relationship to that and one is,
one is,
well maybe it depends on how it is that
you are right?
Because it could be that there are ways
of being in the world that justify the
world and there are ways of being in the
world that make the world unbearable.
And I believe that the narrative that
runs through the biblical stories is
precisely a dialogue between those two
types of being.
And the optimistic part of the story is
that being requires limitation and
suffering.
There's no escape from that.
But there are modes of being that allow
that to be perhaps even more than
tolerable.
Perhaps there are modes of being that
allow that to be good and it's a
straight and narrow road.
It's a very difficult road to tread.
So,
so I think,
well,
that that's possible.
You know,
I'm not an optimist by nature and,
but uh,
that's,
that's one of the things that I've
conceptualized and read about that I
actually find plausible because it's
certainly the case.
Everyone knows this,
that there are ways that you can act and
make things worse.
Everyone knows that.
And so if that's the case,
there has to be the opposite,
right?
There has to be ways that you could act
and make things better.
And obviously you can act in ways that
make things really way worse.
And so the question is,
well,
are there ways that you can actually
make things really much better?
And I think that's the question is can
we have our cake and eat it too?
Can we have the being that requires
limitation and suffering and also
simultaneously transcend that by our
mode of being.
And I believe that the biblical stories
and perhaps not only the biblical
stories,
but the biblical stories,
are they human?
Imagine one of the human imaginations
best attempts to address and answer that
question.
That's what the entire story is about.
So the first of it is the catastrophe of
the collapse of self consciousness and
the entrance of humanity into history.
And the rest of it is,
okay,
now we're in history.
Now we know that we're going to die.
We know about our mortality.
We're conscious of our own being is the
remote of acting in the world that
allows that to be justifiable or maybe
even more that allows that to be
triumphant.
And then I would also say maybe it's
worth finding out.
You know that the other thing that's so
interesting because you've got this
short time on earth and there's lots of
things that are very,
very difficult to contend with and,
and you have the problem of tolerating
yourself even in all your insufficiency
and one of the things that seems to me
to be the case is that if you adopt a
sufficiently profound mode of being,
if you attempt to do that,
then the mere act of lifting up that
weight is enough to justify the fact
that you're insufficient and mortal and,
and,
and bound by tragedy.
And I believe that and I believe people
believe that because if you watch how
people act,
they look for people they admire and
they do admire people,
right?
It's a natural.
It's a natural phenomena.
You see it starting with children being
children admire and then they imitate
and we look to people who seem to be
able to bear the burden of being in a
heroic manner and there's something
inside of us that calls to that and that
makes us want to,
to mimic that and to follow it.
And I think that that's.
I think that that's the deepest and most
profound of instincts and I think it's
right and even if you're not so
convinced on the positive end,
you know,
because it's more difficult to be
convinced of the positive.
You can certainly be convinced on the
negative end because there are ways of
being that are so brutal and so
reprehensible that merely to read about
them is enough to traumatize you.
And I think that if you're a person who
hasn't lost their soul completely,
you can't help but encounter stories
like that and shudder away from them.
And you know,
Alexander Solzhenitsyn,
who,
who was the person who did most
unmasked,
the absolute horrors of communist
totalitarianism,
said that he believed that the Nuremberg
judgments were the most important event
of the 20th century.
And that that was the judgment at the
end of World War II.
That there were certain actions that no
one was to undertake no matter what
their cultural background was because
they were,
let's say,
crimes against humanity.
That there was such a thing as universal
evil.
And you can debate that.
You know,
I mean and,
and,
and people certainly have,
but the problem is,
is if you debate that,
then you have to say that there are
conditions under which the sorts of
things that happen say in the
concentration camps,
which would be the gassing of children
after their torture and,
and they're,
they're forcible removal from their
parents and all the terrible things that
went along with that,
that that's just okay.
It's just an opinion.
It's just something that happened and
there are circumstances under which
that's justifiable if you,
if there's no transcendent,
good and evil underneath that argument,
it's only a matter of practicality and,
and,
and it seems to me that that's,
that's not the right conclusion to draw.
That's how it seems to me.
And that's what Solzhenitsyn concluded
when he looked at the Nuremberg trials.
So the notion that the notion that it
was good,
well even if you don't believe that and
you know,
because maybe it's not as good as it
could be,
I would say it's incumbent on you as
someone who participates.
The process of of furthering creation to
act as if it couldn't be good at least,
and to further that with with all of
your efforts,
part of it because what the hell else do
you have to do that could possibly be
better than that,
that could possibly justify your
existence.
More than that and you know perfectly
well,
if,
if you,
if you have any sense at all,
if you think clearly about it at all,
is that that's what you want to see in
every one else.
You know,
it's,
you're,
you're desperate and maybe you're
cynical and now and then someone appears
that acts at least momentarily,
like a light in the darkness and that
lifts your spirit up and gives you a
little bit of hope and maybe helps you
continue on.
It's well.
That's obviously a call to being.
It's,
it's a,
it's a statement from your own soul that
says,
well,
there's something about that.
That's how you should be,
and maybe then,
well,
we get a chance to,
to participate in what is good.